all right so the menu is now on HBO Max
serving up one heck of a delectable dark
comedy course but uh can can I
substitute the salad for some fries
anyway in this video we're going to be
talking about the ending of this movie
our reaction and review along with what
it's trying to say about those snooty
Foodies out there so with that out of
the way thank you for clicking this
video also hit that like And subscribe
Button as it helps us out I'm your host
Jared now let's get into the menu
[Music]
so essentially the menu features this
lavish one-of-a-kind restaurant the
Hawthorne located on a remote island
owned by celebrity chef Julian slowik
multiple courses only the most elite can
dine here with it being
1250 ahead but don't worry don't worry
the tip is included in that price we're
slowly introduced to the type of people
that dine at such a high class
establishment as one by one they arrive
at the ferry and make their way to the
island a handful of tech Bros a washed
up actor and his assistant an older
couple food critic and the magazine
editor who's working with her and
finally Tyler basically a big Instagram
foodie you know the people that are
constantly taking snapshots of their
food and Margot his girlfriend on the
island they're guided about the grounds
by hongchao's Elsa showing the guests
that everything is grown raised
specifically cultured and hand-picked
from the Island's resources every single
day meaning the freshest of fresh
ingredients in their multiple course
meal however not only Elsa but also Chef
slawick questioned margot's presence on
the island and at the Hawthorne almost a
stand-offish feeling like she is
unwelcome to dine in such class even
though she was invited as Tyler's
partner as the extravagant courses
continue like eating the actual ocean
Things become a bit stranger like a
bread dish without any actual bread
because it's considered peasant food
tortillas that were 3D printed to
Showcase quote sins the guests had
committed like Tyler taking snapshots of
his food without permission the tech
Bros embezzling money and Mr Lee
Brandt's infidelity with Margot all of
which finally takes a dark turn when one
of slowik's Sous chefs shoots himself in
a dish called the mess turning
everything into pure chaos as more more
of the vile guests Natures are revealed
all being part of slow Wick's pre-fixed
menu AKA everyone's gonna die so yeah
this is all a commentary on the one
percent elitist perfectionism the love
of Art and where it makes the turn from
love to Obsession the relationship
between givers and takers the service
industry and how most of the time it is
purely transactional the reason all of
these 12 guests are at the Hawthorne for
this dinner is because one they think
they deserve the best of the best
experience but also because they either
portrayed the vile traits I mentioned or
if slighted Chef slowik in some way or
another Tyler the social media foodie
has taken the joy out of food by
breaking it down by all of its minute
components thinking he too is on the
same level as slowik and the others
mentioning that he had cooked some
googly GOP in a pressure cooker once the
older couple who had ditched out on the
beach slash Island Tour are regulars who
have been to the Hawthorne 11 times
prior but can't name a single dish they
have ever eaten there the tech Bros have
embezzled money and only believe in
wealth status and even throwing around
the do you even know who we are bro line
a nasty food critic who's responsible
for closing multiple restaurants and may
be my favorite a washed up movie star
why is the movie star there well Chef
slawick had his first day off in months
a wonderful Sunday the perfect day to
see a movie well that movie sucked
slowly collaborating that it's when an
artist loses their talent however Margot
is the only person not supposed to be
there not fitting into one of these rich
and snooty archetypes causing slowik to
grow a fondness towards her later
learning that she too is in the service
industry and all woman of the night as
we say not originally being on the guest
list because Tyler had broken up with
his previous partner days prior instead
hiring Margot as plus 1 adding to
Tyler's penis is also the fact that he
knew of the death and suicide that was
going to be going down he had contacted
Chef slowik informing him of everything
that was going to happen like some sort
of celebrity chef simping and instead
still showed up to this event and
brought Margo to suffer from his
mistakes but due to the shared service
industry code between Margot and slowik
she is granted special treatment
choosing to die with either the rich
a-holes or the kitchen staff later
tasked with retrieving a giant Barrel
from the chef's secluded quarters upon
arriving at his home Margot notices
various achievements of Chef slowik all
with a stoic look on his face but one
his very first award for best
cheeseburger at a burger joint shows a
huge grin full of love not Obsession
Margot takes this information upon
herself returning to the Hawthorne with
the barrel and demands her food be sent
back to the kitchen she states that his
menu is nothing but an intellectual
exercise it's not food it's not good it
is taking the Joy from everything much
like all of the others there that night
and worst yet she is still hungry slow
wake uphold never having had this happen
before asks what Margo would Desire with
her stating a cheeseburger and fries a
small glint shines in slow Wick's eye
he'll make her the best cheeseburger
ever but it'll cost her 9.95 nothing but
love is put into this burger and I'm not
gonna lie it looked incredible like my
mouth was watering with Margo responding
mm-hmm
this is a tasty burger basically like
that saying now that's a cheeseburger
however after only having a bite or two
she is full asking if she can get the
rest to go tricky tricky as you can see
Chef slowik boxes it up she pays her
bill and leaves the Hawthorne the
remaining guests are prepped for dessert
s'mores graham crackers are scattered on
the floor vests of marshmallow are added
to the guest with little chocolate hats
as the final component to top everything
off slow wake explains how this fan
favorite dessert is an Abomination
mass-produced dry crackers barely edible
chocolate gelatinized sugar all made
with primitive fire the staff lights
that some beach up burning the guests
staff everything as the Hawthorne
explodes in the distance Margot can be
seen on the boat enjoying the rest of
her Burger wiping her mouth with the
fancy menu
slow Wick had prepared
slowex approach was everything that is
wrong with arts society culture we
strive for Perfection but it is
impossible While others critique this
only consuming rather than tasting they
are never satisfied and as an artist to
appease these people love is lost Joy is
taken out of everything and it is only
an obsession an emotionless husk only
therefore the experience hey we gotta do
it for the gram these people give but
the takers want to continue to take and
take and take even at the end slowwick
realizes that he has turned into one of
these people himself and the
cheeseburger reminds him of the art and
love that started it all a literal Eat
the Rich Approach at the end of the film
with all of them being turned into
marshmallows and lit up but all of the
menu can be applied to that of the film
industry and how too many cooks in the
kitchen can push out something that is
barely consumable but also viewers are
sometimes like the guests some of the
people May instantly forget this film
like the older couple at the Hawthorne
While others break down every single
minute detail Easter egg and theme like
heavy sport I mean Tyler Tyler yes yes
yes Tyler 100 Tyler in the movie in the
end it's an art form and the love for
that art can easily be influenced I had
a blast with the menu the script was so
witty and sharp Anya Taylor joy and
Ralph finds betrayal and chemistry was
top tier all of the other guests and
personas were funny as well I did laugh
pretty hard when one of the tech Bros
was like we kept you open during covid
and the clever ingredient pop-ups
whenever a dish was solved had that
perfect amount of tongue-in-cheek
self-awareness the tension in the first
half shines a bit brighter than the
second and the close-up shots of the
food were so just chef's kiss also it's
pretty ironic to critique the menu as a
work of filmmaking art when that's what
the entire film was sort of saying about
it when when you when you think about it
when you think about it anyway I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the menu did
this dine and death dark comedy serve up
a delicious treat and how many of you
rushed out for a cheeseburger right
after watching the movie and I'll let
you know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
Black Adam and Dawn of the Dead on the
15th of January and all you have to do
to get a chance of winning this is like
this video subscribe with notifications
on and also drop a comment below on your
thoughts of the menu we picked the
comments at random at the end of every
single month and the winners of last
month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos we've done some
kick-ass breakdowns lately so treat
yourself but with that out of the way
thanks for your constant support I've
been Jared I'm gonna head out and grab
myself a cheeseburger so we'll see in
the next one take care and peace
[Music]